welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question it's the show that
gives you too much information about how
much some Marvel heroes hate each
other's guts I'm Erik Bosse filling in
for bill this week our friend Tommy Beck
told nobody great to be here happy to be
here thanks for having me Eric can you
tell us where Phillip is buried Phillip
is he's not buried he's mounting in a
vat of acid so I've been digging under
that septic tank and his husband you
will not find Phillip you will find
Phillip in my new product of hand soaps
and lotions and hair gels that come out
fill me ups you see I have a total
conspiracy that Phillip is Carol Baskins
ex-husband because we don't know how old
he is so yeah a couple days ago we just
did our read breakdown of Captain
America's Civil War and we loved the
movie but as we know from the Marvel
Comics Civil War is a way bigger deal
and now we're in an MCU that has pretty
much everyone involved gang's all here
yeah so hit me with that question Tom
okay so my question for you Eric is what
would a true MCU Civil War look like now
that Marvel has all of their heroes
available to them let's recap here yeah
in the MCU Captain America Civil War was
based on the Civil War of in the comics
and the sokovia accords were like a form
of the superhero oversight registration
the superhero Registration Act as it's
known in the comics so in the movie team
Iron Man who's Pro sokovia accords
includes Tony Stark Rudy Black Panther
vision spider-man and Black Widow though
Natasha changes sides during the airport
battle to be on Team cap team cap who's
anti Accords Captain America Bucky
Falcon Hawkeye Wanda Maximoff and
ant-man so as we know in the film it's
not as much about the accords by the end
of the movie it's it's more personal the
Tony hates Bucky because Bucky killed
his parents he blames Capra defending
them to Charlie hates Bucky for he
thinks is involved in his father's
killing
- never trust Tony Rhodey gets
critically injured that makes it super
personal vision misfires a team cap by
the in the movie it's not about the
Accords it's just Zemo manipulating the
Avengers against each other the way
Tommy is manipulating me and Phillip
against each other that's right the way
I've used marina
joven and all of the other characters as
pawns in my game
the sad part is we know what you're
doing Tommy were just powerless to stop
you who's that in the comics Civil War
is obviously a way bigger deal involves
pretty much all the Marvel Universe it
starts when a superhero fight blows up
six hundred people in Connecticut 60
kids died the public turns against
superheroes they demand the superhero
Registration Act it passes the x-men
declared neutrality they're like we
don't want to pick a side in this
because either way it's lose-lose for us
Ironman leads to pro registration side
cap leads the anti registration side
spider-man starts off with team Iron Man
he outs himself big press conference big
deal but then later at the end of the
war he switches sides to cap he's
horrified by the enforcement things that
they're that they're pulling Tony and
Reed Richards bring in this what people
think is Thor but really it's like a
clone of Thor that is called Ragnarok
it kills Bill Foster Goliath yes a big
big moment and then the war ends with
Capps surrendering but he gets
assassinated huge moment in Marvel
Comics so let's apply this to the MCU
now with all the characters who were
there all the characters who did not
appear in the Civil War film which side
would they be on and since we don't
really know we're gonna use some
standards here first standard how their
characters cited in the comics to what
their longtime alliances are with other
characters 3 their general attachment to
Earth's politics and laws do they care
for their general moral alignments we're
gonna apply some D&D gridding here and
then 5 whether they wear a mask because
as we saw in the Civil War event they're
whether or not they're a public
superhero is it is a big part of it do
they want to reveal themselves reveal
their real name
to this public oversight or they just
like whatever everyone knows who I am
anyway you can learn a lot by someone by
whether they wear a mask
especially now more than ever Tommy will
you please wear a mask when you go
outside I always wear masks I've been
wearing masks for years people used to
beg me not to
now they demand that I do how do you see
these things coming you must have been
involved were you a part of that
chemtrail conspiracy Tommy what happened
is I have an orb in my basement that
talks to me if I do its bidding it will
reward me with little glimpses into the
future for instance Eric I wouldn't get
sushi next week oh why why Tommy Tommy
Tommy tells Tommy tells us your news oh
right
Nostradamus okay first character Hulk
Bruce Banner right he was on Sekar
during civil war and the comics he was
also offworld during this event wasn't
really involved but when asked about an
interview Robert Downey jr. Chris Evans
Giarrusso they all weighed in Evans said
that banner would be on Team Iron Man
because Natasha was on that team at the
beginning Joe Russo said that banner
would never side with Thaddeus Ross
because that was his main antagonist in
the first Hulk film but Robert Downey
jr. said that banner Antonio science
dudes and I side with Robert Downey jr.
banner has a profound sense of
responsibility and guilt over his
collateral damage he would definitely
agree with the sokovia chord so I say
Hulk team Iron Man yeah he's amongst the
more reluctant heroes right not yet not
that he is reluctant to commit heroic
acts but that he's reluctant to exist in
general yeah like he doesn't he feels as
though he's a burden on everyone and
unfortunately through literally means
beyond his control he often is a burden
on everyone because of the destruction
caused us to halt so I can't see him
fighting against it I feel like you're a
hundred percent correct yeah moving on
to Thor okay so Thor was also offworld
during the event he was exploring the
nine realms Eddie was seeking the stones
but that wasn't really the case in the
comics he was also offworld but yeah as
I said there was like a Thor clone that
was involved Chris Evans said that Thor
would be on Team cap and in
MCU the war is really not that concerned
with the politics of Earth he probably
would not he's a demigod he wouldn't
concede to their oversight but I also
just don't think he would be opinionated
enough to fight his fellow Avengers so I
would say I would label Thor as neutral
to this conflict and I would also throw
in most of the Asgardians Valkyrie in
their friends Korg and meek Heimdall I
think whether they're up world or
whether this is later in the timeline
where they're on new as God on earth I I
think they would say we're neutral to
this you guys figure it out we're not
gonna turn our piss against each other
in this yeah I think these subservience
parties the ludicrous part that he would
they would never go for them I'm here to
talk to you about the Avenger initiative
I can't see any of the audience walking
in with their handcuffs they're
voluntarily registering to be monitored
by any sort of earth government what has
guardian who has volunteered his hands
to be in cuffs is Loki so you know Loki
is both alive and dead at the same time
these days and a few but he is
definitely uninterested in political
squabbles unless they could benefit his
goals this guy's a master of
Machiavellian so I would imagine him
seeing these sokovia accords as making
earth superheroes more controllable and
easier to manipulate and conquer so I
could see Loki trying to game this and
join Team Iron Man in a civil conflict
that would be very interesting and very
funny watching Loki metal and government
affairs like that and basically whatever
his end goal is which is always
something that's I mean like it's always
something absolutely epic in scale of
like total he wants to be the absolute
authoritarian leader or it's like he
wants a snack it's like there's no
in-between there's something horribly
huge or something like he was bored that
day yep okay let's move on to Captain
Marvel so during the Civil War event
Carol Danvers was then known as miss
marble and she supported registration
she was on Team Iron Man however the
Carol Danvers and then see is based on
the 2011 relaunch of the character that
MCU identity is more aggressive and
stubborn she goes her own way she defies
orders she also has had some bad
experience with like conspiracies and
gaslighting by the Kree supreme
intelligence she doesn't trust higher
authorities I would think she would
that the safest hands are her own and
she would probably join teamcap yeah
that's kind of another like I think
Steve Rogers taking the stance that he
did was kind of a swerve like Carol
Danvers is like you know she's a soldier
she was in the you know she was in the
military and like so you would assume
there would be an element of her that
would want to fall in line that way but
I think you're right with the rebooted
character having kind of a an attitude
like that yeah I think you're like
you're dead-on with that one again Eric
good job yes I am the authority you know
disagree more am I just telling you what
you want to hear as part of a bigger
plot loci I just want an echo chamber
agree sir
let's quickly check it on Doctor Strange
he was around during this event but
those are the ancient one of the other
sorcerers they didn't get involved
because there they serve a thority
that's beyond the laws of man they will
remain neutral as well they've seen too
much stuff in their lives that like when
these things happen they already know
how they like half of them probably have
already been to the future and know how
it turns out of they're just like okay
that's just like them the Wizards of the
Harry Potter universe they avoid all
political matters including World War
two which nowadays makes them Nazi
sympathiser that's right Harry Potter is
a tough one pack that it's like the
further down the logic rabbit holes you
go with that the board Wizards are just
monster purple people they make their
poop disappear - they just teleport
which we'll be talking more about that
subject later but like there's an
element of JK Rowling Oh for sharing
things about the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter where I'm like god I get it
this is you're like crazy world that you
created that's incredibly creative but
like we don't need closure on everything
we don't need answers there are some
questions that the mystery is more fun
than the solution speaking of mystery
let's move on to Nick Fury so Nick Fury
didn't pick a side during civil war in
the MCU in the Marvel companion comics
with the movie civil war he and Maria
Hill were like kind of watching it on
with sadness as the Avengers fought each
other like I wish we could do something
one would think Nick Fury would be Pro
sokovia courts because he has in the
past favored big government control over
superhero
he wants them as a weapon in his arsenal
but we saw in Winter Soldier he
definitely learned that he could no
longer trust the government to oversee
anything and civil war is post Hydra
shield so yeah I would definitely say
Nick Fury would be team cap during a
civil war conflict now along with Nick
Fury would probably be characters like
wasp Janet Van Dyne and Hank Pym now
Hank Pym is usually aligned with Tony
Stark but in the MCU their frequent
lawbreakers they say never trust a stark
so like Scott Lang they would also be
team cap that to me is a hugely valuable
swerve yeah be on Team cap because the
the just the technology alone that they
possess sure yeah they have access to
the quantum realm they can shrink they
can time travel that's a huge benefit
for Team cap now on to the people of
Wakanda so T'Challa of course supports
team Iron Man and with that would
probably be a co a and Shuri
they're very loyal to T'Challa however
mbaku
is interesting right I would imagine in
Baku would be less willing to consent to
this oversight from a foreign authority
he doesn't even trust the wakandan
throne that much I would imagine Baku
would probably side with team cap now
let's move on to other characters in the
AMC the guardians of the galaxy another
thing about them is the guardians of
galaxy that we know were based on the
Abnett and Lanning relaunch the
characters in 2008 they weren't really
part of the Civil War event and I would
imagine they don't really give a [ __ ]
about Earth's politics so I would
imagine they remain neutral along with
everyone else in their world characters
like the Ravagers Adam warlock
yeah if they have cared they'd be like
so what's going on on earth right ok
we'll just go fly over to holla or we'll
go over to Xander we'll be okay right
let's move on quickly to the characters
who we know are upcoming to the MCU who
are there and they're gonna be in movies
in the next couple years shang-chi so in
the civil war comics Shang Shu is part
of the Heroes for Hire who are pro
registration and I would say as an enemy
to the Mandarin of the ten rings also
enemies to Tony Stark the MCU shang-chi
from what we know about it would
probably be team Iron Man the Eternals
are coming up the Eternals those
[ __ ] have stayed out of everything
they're the Wizards yeah why would they
intervene
now Eternals are gonna stay neutral and
see this out now blade is an interesting
one we know mercial ollie is coming up
to play blade sometime in the future and
the civil war comics blade is is one of
the enforcers who helps hunt down
superheroes he is a monster hunter he
likes to kill vampires III would think
he would be Pro Accords in order to rein
in the other vampiric and other demonic
entities around the world
he might be team Iron Man and he's a
very tunnel vision superhero he could he
could singularly focus the thing that
always sways these heroes morally in the
movies and sometimes in the comics is
when they they have a new element of
something to care about where his blades
kind of got a singular yes blade
wouldn't have a philosophical objection
to this kind of thing neither would she
hold Jennifer Walters is a lawyer she's
out in the public she doesn't hide her
identity and she's cousins with Bruce
Banner we've considered Bruce to be on
Team Iron Man as she is in the comics I
would say she would be team Iron Man I
love it
she's just talked to me you know I don't
feel the need to gender my Hawks but I
would like her to represent me in the
court of love now let's quickly checking
with Miss Marvel and spectrum they seem
like they're aligned with Carol Danvers
they're very super-powered I would say
they probably agree that the safest
hands are her own I would put them on
Team cap and lastly who watches The
Watcher is technically join the MCU
played by Jeffrey Wright in the Marvel
what if show he is a watcher by
definition they don't intervene they
just observe and record he is neutral by
definition he has to be otherwise he
doesn't get to be the watcher he's the
doer I'm doing he just likes to watch
kind of like you yeah I mean I'm a big
time watcher very infrequently a
participator but more than when I am
it's usually just tickles boy all right
now our last category people are people
we know are coming to the MC probably
the rumored MCU joiners soon okay the
Fantastic Four in the comics is
interesting they're split Reed Richards
supports registration sue and Johnny are
against it Ben is neutral I would say in
the MCU
applying these things Reed Richards he
is the man of science in order he is
very much aligned with Tony Stark's way
of thinking he would probably be team
Iron Man and I agree I think su store
and Johnny Storm would probably be team
cap because Sue Storm Invisible Woman
Johnny Storm a guy who likes to go zone
character I can do this all day I don't
know Ben Grimm would would stay neutral
I feel like he would pick a side it's
easier to make a neutral choice in a
comic where you forget about characters
for pages at a time huh it would be very
hard for him to just sit there be like
well know what I wanna do yeah I know
both sides make relevant point there's
many fine people on both sides of the
ocean that wouldn't be the bedroom we
know however Victor Von Doom he is
defined in his like moral alignment as a
lawful evil and I could see him joining
teamironman has seen like you know what
registration is the smart way to go I'm
going to use this for evil reasons but
for right now I'm going to join mr. Tony
Stark in registering everybody and
hunting them down okay we also have
gotten pseudo confirmation that Namor
might be joining the MCU he's an
original Avenger and I don't know in my
view kind of like Black Panther he's the
ruler of a hidden nation he's a man of
laws and he might benefit from fewer
superheroes running around causing chaos
in the ocean I would say he might join
Team Iron Man characters like Nova and
Silver Surfer I kind of lumped them in
with the guardians of the galaxy don't
care about Earth's conflicts neutral and
let's like about the mutants
okay civil war was all about the mutants
and them running amuck because there's
so many of them Cyclops Kanan said the
x-men are going to be neutral later on
Wolverine and storm ended up fighting on
team cap Bishop it's of supporting
superhero registration and the MCU we
don't really know about the mutants yet
they're kind of an unknown quantity I
would just running through them quickly
I think Wolverine would be teamcap he
doesn't want to play by the rules
push off Cyclops and Jean Grey and
Professor X I think team Iron Man
Drake done lioness magneto would be team
cat I don't think he wants to trust the
government
a rogue I also think would be team cap
and yeah I think storm and beast as
people playing within the system would
be on Team Iron Man as well the Young
Avengers most of them in the comics
Wiccan hoechlin patriot cape bishop
they're on team cat because they don't
try
but weirdly stature cassie lang is pro
registration in the comics and thinking
about it that might make sense
cassie lang I could see her falling far
from the tree and supporting teamironman
in this kind of conflict kids love to
rebel against their parents irk I want a
rock let's check in with Deadpool real
quick
in the comics Deadpool obviously is
always like a chaotic neutral you know
it's whatever the situation calls him to
be but he weirdly is pro registration as
another enforcer like blade he tracks
down superheroes or anti-registration
and drags them back in in the MCU I
could imagine a Deadpool wanting to be
eager to play by the rules be accepted
by the Avengers by this universe so yeah
I can see a version of the Merc with a
mouth beam hunter to endear himself to
Tony Stark so I'm gonna put Deadpool on
Team Iron Man for now looking at the
other defenders daredevil Jessica Jones
Luke Cage iron fist in the comics
they're team cap because many of them do
have secret identities not Luke Cage but
daredevil obviously still wears a mask
they don't want to play by those rules
Eddie Brock venom he's kind of like Hulk
not totally in control he in the comics
is part of Team Iron Man I think he
would be in the in the movie as well
okay so to wrap this all up in summary
with this new version of all these
characters aligned on different sides
team Iron Man I think would have more of
an edge - gee Hulk they have Hulk they
have half the mutants the main
difference is the MCU is a place where
superheroes generally don't use their
secret identities that was a choice made
early on by Kevin Feige and John Favreau
and Robert Downey jr. characters don't
have as much to hide so they have less
to lose by supporting Tony so I think in
general team Iron Man would have the
edge in the MCU I agree I think the
stronger yeah and if you think about it
like especially post end game when the
sokovia accords were instituted everyone
kind of turned on the Avengers because
they don't really know what happened but
when the snap happened
everyone just it away and all they
really know is that Iron Man Tony Stark
made a sacrifice to bring everyone back
so I would say the public would rally
around someone like Ironman whereas
people like Captain America Bucky they
aren't the heroes they once were anymore
they were from a different era and I
think people would be like now let's
just register all these guys so we can
organize but I think the caveat is
Marvel could do a Civil War 2.0 over a
different debate I mentioned genetic
lineage like maybe deviant linked people
on one side eternals linked on another
like scrolls are derive from the
deviance that could be a big thing that
could draw in everyone no matter what
planet they're on in the MCU
but that's speculative that should maybe
be a different movie you could have
Secret Wars come in that divide people
if you're talking about what is the
classic Marvel Civil War it's over
Supergirl registration will save those
other ideas for a future rogue theory
episodes but Tommy my question for you
is do you think Marvel should reboot the
Civil War event in a different reality
or should they do it over a different
issue what do you think I think well in
the movies the cleanest way to kind of
pay homage to the fact they have these
new characters would be in like
multiverse of madness to just briefly
show us five minutes of the Civil War in
a different dimension
they'll show the airplane airport scene
battle again but have x-men in there
wholly sit that's a great idea
I think a full reboot of the Civil War
as much as I love that comic I had the
physical the actual main run of it that
I also have all this what-ifs and the
the companion like what were the
Fantastic Four to like the specific what
everyone was doing the sidekicks I when
I was younger I read every single one of
those but yeah I just feel like it was
such a huge undertaking to make that
Captain America Civil War movie like to
rebut it now would just be like I know
it kind of undercuts the impact of that
which I thought was a great movie I
would hesitate to do that I would more
make nods to the comic line and the
newly acquired characters that they have
the IP for now totally agree I think
there is a way that you could still
deliver on that kind of fanservice by
having x-men fighting Avengers or
Avengers 2 versus Dark Avengers like
there's still way you can have fights
between superheroes but it's coming up
with a new title and the Civil War is
obviously a huge event
we wanted it to be more than it was but
we can just tell news stories that
deliver that kind of thing well tell me
I'm gonna let you finish this second
just want to take a moment to remind
everyone watching that new rock stars
has been trying our best to keep these
daily doses a distraction coming your
way during this period but it has not
been easy YouTube isn't exactly
compensating us very fairly regardless
of what kind of views we get which is
insane our government loan requests sir
not being responded to our plan to try
to get through this it's to partner with
another small business trying to help us
all a small business called sanitize and
chill so sanitize and chill combines
hospital-grade ethanol-based hand
sanitizer with CBD and nori we have been
making sure this product is actually
effective at killing viruses we're
working very closely with a company
we're getting some medical professionals
to make sure it meets the highest levels
of guidelines so here's the deal there's
no THC in the stuff so you're not gonna
get high using it but your hands will
get clean and it's green because it
contains aloe vera to keep your hand
smooth and aloe vera is amazing every
bottle this has 100 milligrams of CBD an
alcohol content on the sanitizers above
the 60 percent level threshold and CDC
recommends for inactivating viruses and
the other labels that you're familiar
with this is 70 percent alcohol it's
stronger than those brains that we took
for granted that we can't really find on
the shelves and are crazily marked up on
online retailers there is a limited
supply of less than 2,500 bottles
because of the small size of the company
and the quality of this stuff so if you
are looking for hand sanitizer and you
want to try to help us out
act now go to bitly comm slash in our
chill and use the code new rockstars 10
at checkout for 10% off your order all
right we're gonna move on to a
bite-sized question that Tommy has done
the research and he's the expert on this
cuz last time he was on the show he knew
all about this subject
Tommy yes which non-human Marvel
characters poop yes and I'm gonna give
you five that I'm most curious about yes
Hulk
nanos Groot nebula and vision do they
well they say everybody poops Eric the
books say that but that's not sure I did
some research here and I have some
theories let's let's go let's tick them
off one by one Hulk
okay okay Hulk definitely first of all
I'm just going to boiler alert we in
endgame he's eating yet he's eating
breakfast food then later he'd spend a
Jerry's ice cream constant eating
so I'm sorry it doesn't just go away
that has to come out however there is
comic-book precedence for this in the
Marvel zombie comic line zombie Hulk
eats so much human flesh that when he
turns back into Bruce Banner Bruce
Banner has an excruciating stomach ache
that he almost dies from so the answer
is the Hulk takes massive dumps but it's
better if he dumps as Hulk because
unlike Ant Man who it's just the
distance between atoms when he shrinks
and then expense of everything [ __ ]
shrinks and expands on a molecular level
the Hulk is gaining muscle mass and
gaining tissue and everything but he's
the the mass of what he eats remains the
same when it comes time to perspire sigh
so is he very careful if Hulk doesn't
take dumps if banner takes a Hulk
Guppies go to the emergency room that's
a good point and in the comics it's rare
that we see Hulk actually eating because
he's usually just too mad to focus on
sitting down and eating a taco pie -
yeah and the MCU that guy consumes quite
a bit so where does it go alright so
next we'll go vision this is a pretty
easy one vision is made of vibranium and
synthetic tissue much like Superman he's
powered by the Sun he's solar-powered so
he does not need to eat or drink he does
not need to poop he doesn't eat anything
he simply needs to charge up like a
solar battery however his powers when
he's on planets that have different Suns
if there's like there's a comic book sir
Landry goes the planet has like a
negative Sun and it makes him weak and
he becomes almost depowered so he does
not poop to answer that question and I
guess that makes sense in the MCU he
makes the Pepper cash but he doesn't
know he doesn't taste it he doesn't
really understand digestion or
consumption so yes now it's a tough one
because he does in the comics that
established that he does like all plants
use photosynthesis in waste product is
oxygen which is really candy for us
Terrans however in a draft of guardians
of the galaxy - the only line that made
it in was drag saying I had famously
huge turds
but there's another line before that
that is Peter quill telling group when
he's baby Groot that he has to start
aiming for the box implying that he's
excreting some sort of waste and this
isn't necessarily poop but when they
jump through hyperspace
group vomits implying that he has
something in his stomach so there is
right precedent which that's just too
much going on I mean like for me that
would just be that's a long weekend yeah
oh boy nebula Network oops but very
infrequently
okay so popular has again we have to
kind of do if this is true then this is
also true we don't really have a lot of
cinematic or literate 'iv proof of
nebula taking a dump which God if you're
out there and you're an artist get to
work on that I'll pay top dollar but uh
she does eat she requests raw vegetables
million guardians of the galaxy to she
also mentions being hungry to Tony Stark
however when her and Tony Stark are kind
of shipwrecked if you will on their
spaceship Tony is wasting away and she
is not really showing as much physical
trauma so it suggests that her digestive
system moves much slower her her heart
probably beats much slower everything
probably just moves it's such a slower
calmer level which is why you know she's
able to live longer and and just and
withstand more traumatic physical
circumstances so I would say that nebula
definitely takes a dump every once in a
while but it's just very precise it's
very precision that's why we never see
it she's got a secret bathroom somewhere
she comes back in here I go she must
have had to go do something Mel letter
or something last but not least
Big Daddy Thanos mr. thickness he
absolutely 100% takes dumps he loves to
eat
he has an anus as we know from the
famous theory people such as Neil
deGrasse Tyson have weighed in on this
and Neil actually believes due to Thanos
is high stress and an rancid personality
that his bowel movements would be
extremely pungent and unpleasant I guess
there's some sort of science linking
people that are evil to have an evil
bowel movements or having a particularly
unpleasant bump it's so oh my god and if
you remember an endgame again this is
one of those that this is sure than this
Lester Thanos is harvesting those gourds
when he's out in the fields like I don't
know unless he's making really
woodwind instruments or decoration I
assume he's making them for food right
yeah we've done that a big question
before what was that us cooking I think
we concluded as some kind of like
butternut squash stew or your borscht
maybe some sort of gourd gazpacho but
either way if something comes in it's
got to come out we learned that day one
of you so I think there's definitely
poops I think it definitely smells and
he definitely doesn't use any spray just
walks out lets you marinate it if you're
the next one in I bet people have died
from noses dumps so yeah that's what I
got for you that's the straight straight
talk for me Tommy I'm so relieved only
you can answer these kind of questions I
don't know why you're so fascinated by
them Tommy maybe it's just we keep
assigning them to you what commits I'm
pretty spent but I think we have time
for one mailbag question let's see here
the question is what moment made you
realize that you should never meet your
heroes
so as comedians or you know as
attempting to be comedians we have our
comedic heroes and man can that be a
slippery slope I had dinner with a
comedian friend of mine who was very
very nice and another friend of his and
we had dinner the three of us for an
hour and a half and that person never
looked at me never talked to me when my
friend referenced me that person ignored
him when I talked to that person he
ignored me at the end of the night I
shook hands with my friend I went to say
goodbye to him he reached out his hand
epithet eclis like this to give me a
fist bump
still didn't say anything and I have to
say that's why I'm not a man not you
know I interviewed for it's offered and
I found him to be very nice
unfortunately it was it was a friend who
got me the interview and I didn't
realize to be in the room to interview
me it was for like a researcher position
and I hadn't seen enough episodes and
they asked me what was my favorite bit
from a recent season and I couldn't my
mind went blank and I mentioned
something that was from season one and
it's like my biggest like I mean what is
wrong with me and also
make this is the caveat I give to all
celebrities and people who are in the
public eye everybody has a bad day yeah
I have no idea what was going on with
him he might have just been broken up
with he would have gotten some bad
career news maybe he just didn't want to
talk to something like 23 year old
[ __ ] who his friend dragged along to
dinner so looking at it from his point
of view maybe I was the monster that
night so let's bring him on the show
hear his side of the story
by the way I think he's absolutely
hilarious and I just did not have good
dinner with him so you never meet your
heroes okay my story Tommy I can't
remember you might have been here for
this so viewers watching Tommy and I
were on multiple improv teams together
at our ole theatre io West RIT actually
our IP every Improv Theater how could
you see me just close oh boy that's a
sinking ship everywhere
[Music]
okay but Tommy and I were on multiple
teams and one of the teams we were on
was called the cartel it was a team with
so many funny people but just like Tommy
I think he would agree a lot of just
like missed connections like play well
with each other right what do I do their
own so you know I look back on that
experience is only a fond moment you
know the people on my team that I
performed with yeah absolutely
well cartel was one of these teams like
many teams at that theater at the time
just could not have a good show just was
not connecting and it was so frustrating
like I know everyone on this team is
super funny we're just aren't connecting
finally we did have what I thought was
like an a-minus show and it we all got
offstage we're high five and we're like
yes we did it we did I don't know if you
were on the team at this time or if you
were there for that show but afterwards
we come down we go out the back door of
the theater our theater was known to
produce some relatively famous alumni
and there was one actor who took classes
at our theater who went on to become a
very famous TV actor Emmy Award winning
sitcom actor Tommy I'm gonna tell you
his name for this I was not there for
that show but I know this story okay yes
so this guy randomly shows up on this
sidewalk and this is like a back alley
sidewalk that most of the time it's just
homeless people in crazy tourists so to
see this famous Emmy Award winning
hilarious actor come up to us he goes
guys guys I just saw your show do you
mind if I give you some notes normally
the process of giving an improv team
notes is reserved for the coach of that
team the team invites like an expert a
veteran to sit in on the show give them
notes afterwards but someone like this
guy we're like sure give us all the
notes see what he was sweating bullets
beet-red seemed kind of nuts and he was
giving us the worst notes ever we had a
great show but he like clearly was out
of the loop hadn't taken an improv class
in years was giving us like these
old-school level 1 notes that did not
apply to our show like most the time you
take the note but
all of us are looking at each other were
like this guy's full of [ __ ] but because
he's famous we're gonna take the notes
but I was just flattered that he that he
watched her show right this is why I
didn't want to meet my hero afterwards
we went back to the bar I went to go
watch a couple more shows I had a friend
from out of town who had just moved to
LA and she was hanging out in the bar
and he made some very very inappropriate
passes to her and said some very
disgusting things to her and that's why
I'm not saying his name because I'm
waiting for his name to come out right
now and in this era I might have just
been a bad night it might have just been
an isolated incident there might have
been others that's the kind of behavior
that you hear from people like oh that's
never okay in any circumstance it's
probably someone who did that kind of
thing because they knew they could get
away with it because they're in any
winner so it broke my heart a little bit
very nice public face you know what I
mean person yeah you would never suspect
it for nice no sir
sometimes those that gives people a
little more leeway in that department
cause it can be like oh he's so nice
like you would never so nice to him
really never meet your hero and to me
the reason I remember this is like it
was the cartel's one great show dish
like that team what existed for like
five years had the most rotating yeah
everyone was on the cartel at some point
and then it could just never connect and
finally it happened and it was the same
night that this weird ass incident
happened and I'll never forget it never
meet your heroes you never ever meet
your heroes and that's the lesson from
civil war yes these heroes are people
they should meet each other well that is
our show Tommy thanks so much for doing
this with me this week is so great to
have you on thank you for having me as
always it's a joy to talk to you and I
miss you I miss you too buddy
soon sooner or later we'll be back doing
an improv show having that Emmy winners
sexually harassing our team absolutely
we'll be opening up doorways for serial
harasses to run rampant on our female
friends ain't that America
Oh God
ain't that America
[Laughter]
hey a reminder that you can join our
official discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rock stars that's
where we usually see these questions
first we have a whole channel just to
submit questions you can of course tweet
at us questions you can comment in this
video but the best way to get these
questions directly on our desk in front
of us is by joining our discord server
also you can get an audio version of
this show by subscribing to the new rock
stars big question podcast feed wherever
you get your podcasts Thanks to everyone
who submitted questions this episode you
can also mail us your questions by mail
it to our Pio Box address here you can
follow me Eddie a vos followed Tommy at
Tommy Bechtold on a all social media and
of course followed new rock stars and
social subscribe here on YouTube to get
too much information on all the stuff
you care about Tommy what do you try to
plug here this is my new book the
Christmas donkey it's a little golden
book and you can buy it in stores
anywhere Oh Merry Christmas that's when
this is airing right yes who knows all
right everybody see you next week bye
[Music]